everybody welcome my name is Spencer
shinai de Bock and I'm here to tell you
about a maintainable opinionated and
since I'm opinionated right way to build
applications using ASP net core
specifically REST API or API is in
general can I get a quick show of hands
how many people are using asp net core
today okay a few of you good good how
many are using I'm going to use this a
lot old asp net web api like i don't
think it's although I think it's awesome
cool a lot of you okay so what I'm
telling you today I mean it has core in
the title but everything I'm telling you
today applies just as well to asp net
web api there's a couple of things you
need to change other than that it's
pretty much mostly the same so if you
have any questions about anything please
reach out to me I have my contact
information on on the slides so oh and
action item Bach on Twitter so good way
to get a hold of me first thing that I
have to say is that of my co-host
Heather and I are doing a interview show
with some of the top speakers here at
NBC and it's coming July 15 so keep an
eye out for it we've got some really
cool things they teach you something in
five minutes it's awesome okay
housekeeping thing number two is I
already talked about PubCon right
awesome everything that you see
everything that I'm telling you you can
add you can add me on Twitter at night
and box you know I wouldn't you know try
to spell it it's just take a picture
right or you can go to rest Knives net
the precursor to this talk which is
which is restful api design which was
given to them you see that recording is
available I highly recommend you watch
it if you are looking to create your own
REST API and everything that I'm talking
about all the resources everything at
rest is met I don't get paid to say that
even though it's my website there's no
ads so I'm not making any money it's
really to help you all the resources
rest at tonight's net okay awesome so
let's set the stage a little bit right
so you your boss comes to you you're a
web developer and a lot of asp net
developers in here which is awesome a
love HP net and he says he or she says
we need a new single page application
right where we need a new REST API
you did something that our customers
want to be able to consume they want to
get data out of our API they want to
create data inside of our application we
want to create a system where they can
integrate really well I'm an integration
specialist so that's like really
important to me so you say awesome okay
I can do that I'm a discerning developer
I know exactly what I need to do I'm
going to fire up asp net core right or
old asp net web api right hold because I
still use asp net web api out of
curiosity how many web forms people here
this is my favorite question to ask
because inevitably there's like a couple
of hands that like creep up silently but
they don't want to admit it but look I'm
a web forms developer - okay awesome
right and I saw another guy over here
right so web forms you probably can't do
this stuff but still cool to use right
maybe not but anyways I always like to
ask that question so old-old is relative
again all of this applicable to asp net
web api right so you're going to choose
one of those two things and you want to
go from zero to make magic happen
as quickly as possible right like you
want to see something on the page your
angular developer your react developer
or you want to see a record go to the
database so you want to make something
that gets you from zero to make magic
happen as quickly as possible right you
want to do something right and the first
thing you think of is scaffolding
scaffolding scaffolding is great right
it's the promise is that it's amazing
and that it's productivity and
awesomeness and in a lot of ways it is
scaffolding is cool scaffolding is magic
right it's kind of the promise right and
it's very easy to do right let's take a
tour let's take a tour of a scaffold and
application of a scaffolded asp net web
api application in this case it's core
all in Visual Studio right because
Microsoft provides all this great
tooling to you might as well use it
right but first let's introduce our
friend the employee object let's say
your system that has a representation
for employees right you have an ID you
have a first and last name you notice
are decorated with the required
attributes because they're required data
and you've got a date of birth and a
date of hire and a social security
number wait e8 where am i what what the
heck is a social security number I made
this mistake in London I had to slide up
and I was like oh I don't know that they
know what a social security number is I
need to make that mistake again so
I'm in Norway so I'm going to talk about
the birth number or the national ID
number right or that word right so you
the bottom line is is that it's the
employee object is an object that is
part of a payroll system right something
like that a lot of people deal with
payroll a lot of people deal with
employee records in some way kind of
contain sensitive data in this case
we'll just say SSN but national ID
number birth number whatever you want to
call it it's sensitive data so you need
to treat it you need to treat it
differently right you need to treat it
in a way that you need to encrypt it
right all that kind of stuff so I'm
setting the stage a little bit right and
you're the developer you love Visual
Studio and you love visual Studios
tooling and you love to get stuff done
so what do you do you go to file new
project and you choose asp net core and
then maybe you add any framework right
this is opinionated talk I like entity
framework you may use something
different and that's ok you may use web
api plus something complete you may use
n hibernate and that's ok right all of
these things so these are the this is
the core of your application right
you've got a something that processes
requests something that talks to a
database you go to file new project and
this is kind of what you're looking at
now for those of you there was about I
think about half of people have looked
at core there's a few things that are
different so first thing and probably
the best change I can think of is now
none of the static files in the code
files and the views and the controller's
the CS files right there used to be in
Web API they're all intermingled they're
all together and then asp net iis just
serves them up differently based on the
file type right and in this case now
core is probably the number one
improvement maybe not the number one
improvement one of the one of the number
one improvements was moving that all to
a WW route so all of your static data
now goes and is served out of that
folder right so if you've got scripts
that's get a script folder inside of the
path you directory you have to do some
kind of process to move those files over
to the WWE directory before they're
served so that's awesome other than that
there's really not much changed you've
still got you've still got controllers
models views those folders stay the same
and oops
and you have this is a little different
so web.config is a little bit some of
its functionality has been replaced with
the app settings JSON file right there's
a couple other things including the
startup dot CS the startups at CES is a
lot different now
used to how many people are familiar
with global dot is ax and you don't have
to play in that phone okay most most asp
net developers are anybody intermingle
it with startup that CS they have both
existing in their web api or MVC project
okay a few of you so start-up CS has
really taken the place of what global
dot s ax really did which is just like
handle the startup of the application
right you're handling the startup of the
application and you're defining in this
file this is a little different from
startup that CS that you use a web api
you're defining all the services that
are used inside of your application
right so this is all the stuff that core
needs to run and nothing is put there by
default when you new up a Web API or an
MVC project the handlers for asp net web
api and MVC they run through when you
make a request they run through well
maybe this needs to handle it no need to
pass it on to this need to pass it on to
this right it goes through a chain of
processes and it'll always run every
time in the Nate and asp net core you
don't have that you don't need that so
you actually opt in to everything you
don't even serve static files by default
you have to add in you have to opt it
you have to opt those things in right
you get to pick and choose what you want
but most people will start with just add
MVC right and that will give them all of
their this particular line will give
them all of the services that their MVC
application needs to run it'll make
their controllers work it'll put in
routing all of that good stuff it makes
those things available to the asp net
core pipeline right ok and then you
notice a little bit different there is
an ad DB context which is an extension
method on your app builder ok and that
is simply says I want to make an
application DV context available to my
request pipeline as well so that way if
a certain controller or service is
requesting that it will get it will get
instantiated with this connection string
and injected right into that controller
and we'll see an example of that in just
a second but
first you notice of course we've got our
employee object our employee object is
now inside of our project folder so
we've added our employee model there's
all that code and the first number right
and then you're like okay well now I've
connected entity framework so just as an
example right because the tooling likes
entity framework so now we've got our
model now we're going to add our
controller and we're going to scaffold
it's going to be awesome right so you're
going to right click on your controller
we're going to go to add your
controllers folder you're going to right
click on it you're going to say add
controller and there it is right at the
top ready and then you're going to have
a list of choices and your list of
choices is going to include we're going
to select the bottom one right so you
can do empty readwrite actions you can
just do an empty controller you can do
one that serves up views an MVC
controller in this case we're going to
do an API so we're going to select the
bottom one and we're going to say hey
we're going to use entity framework with
it and we want you to we want to
scaffold up all the readwrite actions
for this controller so then you get a
nice handy little dialog box that says I
pick your employee click your pick your
application DB context you're using and
then say the name of the controller
right it's that simple
and then you'll sit you'll hit OK and
end it in asp net and visual studio
actually will go through and scaffold up
those controllers it will make one for
you and then you've got yourself a wild
employees controller it has appeared in
your solution and it's awesome right
because it's got a bunch of stuff so
let's look at the first thing the first
thing that's a little different about it
from when you did this in web api how
many people use scaffolding in the past
a fair number of you I'd say ok less of
you than I thought but still a good
number so generate it's just code Jen
right it's generating all this awesome
code for you right get you started
quickly so it's got an employee's
controller right off the top there
decorated with something like that says
produces right and it says that by
default request to this produce
application jason which is different how
many people when they're using web api
had to go through and the default
serializer was XML and they had to
remove it or make sure that when jason
they wanted to serve jason right it's
default by a default request I see a few
hands go up you don't have to do that
now you can just decorate the controller
and say request of this will prove
produced application Jason
then you say I've got a default route
this is a little bit different if you
use route attribute if you use routing
attributes in Web API this is a little
different now it's just called route and
you say API slash employees okay so all
the requests from there on we'll look at
if you go to API slash employees that
it'll route that request naturally if
it's a get request for the rather to the
get to post request it'll route it to
the post and so on and then this is the
biggest change which is thou the the
application dbcontext
is now injected into your controller by
the asp net pipeline remember that
inside of our startup CS we injected
that we said we want to make this
service available when you're running
MVC services we want to make this
service available to all the other
services that need it so that's great so
essentially when you make this request
you'll automatically get a new employees
controller and it will instantiate it
with this application dbcontext already
ready to go cool and that's different
from web api scaffolding where you it
would just do up its own application
dbcontext which is not as good which is
bad right because then it's creating its
own things we want to tell it what we
want we'll get to that in a minute then
we do get requests right we've get
something where we just define something
where we say I want to get all employees
for this controller for all the
employees for this particular
organization okay that's a good start
for like maybe if you know a couple
hundred employees that'd be good maybe
there's page there maybe there's a
paging option that you want to add in
we're not going to talk about that but
you look at that you're like okay that's
a good start that's a good way to does a
good way to speak in and then of course
just the single get where you make a
request by ID you say maybe you say does
this person have access to this yes or
no
okay then I'm going to go ahead and send
that back if it's an invalid request for
whatever reason if it's a get request
then I'll return bad request and give
them a nice little message okay so
that's the get request so then we get to
the put request which actually changes
employees now I'm going to talk through
this a little bit because this one's a
little bit weird to me
this doesn't make a lot of sense what
you end up with is of course if Model
state is invalid return bad request
that's a good
start okay but notice that what we're
putting into this request right if you
make a put request to this specific ID
and then you say I'm going to give it
this employee data you notice that
you're using the same entity as you are
you're using the same model your entity
model as the one for the request well
that could be good or bad depending on
your requirements right and we'll get to
that in a little bit well then you say
I'm going to try it and then it's and
then if then it becomes you get this
little check on line 10 ish where you
say if the ID that I passed in is
different from the employee ID that I've
given in my request then return bed
requesting you're like okay why do I
have to give that twice okay whatever
you know I'll just do that that's fine
and then it says I'm going to modify it
said it's modified so entity framework
knows to update it and then it saves it
to the database it is updated okay
alright that's not so bad
otherwise we'll return will reduce if
there's a problem doing that we will
return a different error message
depending on the problem right and then
of course we get to the post request
which is a little bit simpler because
it's just creating an employee right
then you're just adding it to the
context and you're validating it adding
it to the context and then you're saving
it to the database cool right and then
of course the delete you may do
something where you're deleting it
straight from the database you may have
a soft deleted kind of situation where
you just want to mark it as delete it
inside the database but you don't
actually want to get rid of it by
default web API gives it you don't just
straight removes it from the database
and that's okay right that could be okay
depending on your need so that's a
scaffolded controller so just with a few
clicks you've gotten something that's
great right it's awesome its
productivity it's amazing but I am here
to tell you that in many cases as your
application grows scaffolding is a lie
scaffolding is a lie perpetrated on you
by Microsoft and yes I'm a Microsoft MVP
and yes I can say that but scaffolding
is a lie scaffolding is something that
is great to get started right but in
long term it has some problems because
your controller first of all is a
one-man army your controller is now
responsible for getting the routing
requests kind of the asp net router
system handles that but then once it
gets to the controller the controller's
like oh this is them this is the method
I should use right so it's responsible
for doing that
is good controllers should do that it
should define where the requests should
go but then it's also validating it and
then it's also running the service right
it's updating the database it's deleting
from the database we're adding to the
database or even getting right at doing
everything and then it's returned to the
request which is okay because that's
what a controller is really good at but
your controller in this case is doing
everything and that's a problem because
there's no separation of concerns inside
of your application inside of your
controller specifically your controller
is literally responsible now maybe
that's okay for five controllers but
five hundred we run into some problems
what we're going to do I'm going to
describe to you ways around that and
it's going to be a refactoring exercise
right we're just going to take you
through how I would make it how I would
change this controller to make it better
okay because in the end the controller
should only route the request and return
data that's what it's good at the
controller is good at saying hey this
thing knows how to do this thing so I'm
going to send this request to this thing
so it can do what it does best which is
whatever thing it's requesting okay and
then I'll return the data return
whatever data that it asked me for
another big problem and this is probably
maybe I don't know this is a big problem
to me your entity also is your request
right let's think about that let's think
about that birth number right you may
you may not want that to be something
that you want to be updated maybe that's
a business rule and a little bit it will
be a business rule but in this case you
just don't need it you don't wanted them
have to have the ability to update it so
you just toss it you don't you want to
toss it away right you don't want that
to be something that you wanted them to
update your your consumers are then able
to I don't know over post right they can
add they can change properties that
they're not supposed to change if
they're aware of them things like that
right problems so let's break it up
let's break it apart into all the little
pieces and parse that that is necessary
right so we're going to talk about
something called command query
responsibility segregation okay and this
is a great pattern for basically
separating the requests from the from
the services that run those requests I'm
going to take you through how you might
break that thing down the bottom line is
that we're going to move the validation
the running of our service and the
requests we're going to remove those
all somewhere else right so we're going
to move those out of the controller the
entity is no longer going to be
responsible for being the request object
okay and the and there's a few reasons
why why is that good reliability right
so a reusability and maybe let's say
that you have services that you define
in another assembly and then Web API is
just aware of them right and then it
uses those services to route requests
and do stuff but you may not be able to
predict where you know HTTP is you know
where we do the majority of our work for
our what if we're a web developer but
you don't know maybe somebody else wants
to use that service somewhere down the
rot line you may not be able to predict
that so then you get to be able to reuse
your code right next thing separation of
concerns okay so now everything is
really good at doing the one thing that
it's asked to do the controller right
now is kind of good at doing the few
things that it's been asked to do but by
and large it's really really only good
for one or two things and that's really
where it should where all of its
functionality should stay and then
easier testing right so it becomes much
easier to test these once you have these
individual components right you can
write unit tests for each of those
different things and end up being able
to control and predict where things are
going to fail or if things code changes
somewhere down the line then it will
fail you know it'll fail faster that way
right unit test so let's start with the
request let's break this baby apart
right so same thing same employee object
that we have and you notice that we have
our validation inside of an employee
object more on that a little later
so again the entity is being used for
requests that's a bad thing right
because again for lots of reasons over
posting reasons you may not want them
you may they may not be aware of
properties on there you may not make
them aware of properties on that object
that you don't want to send back and
then when they do a put request they're
not aware of them either so they may
void out those requests in my other rest
awk I talked about where I do exactly
that i under post data I under put data
to a certain endpoint and I didn't know
that doing so would break their
application but it literally broke them
they didn't have any validation which is
a terrible rule anyways but because I
didn't send all the
requisite properties that I was supposed
to do without that I was supposed to
send in this request it ended up making
the applicant put me application in an
illegal state like a state where we just
wouldn't run right there's a lot of
reasons so we want to break that apart
and then we want to we want to separate
the responsibility for model validation
from the model right something else is
probably best suited to validate and
make sure that that model is good okay
so let's refactor let's start by
separating the model from the entity
right so we've got our employee object
but we've got our business rule that
says that when we make a put request we
don't want to be able we want to be able
to have that employee be able to made
with a put request or and with the birth
number with a post request right when
there's on creation but we don't want
that to happen when they update it now
this is a really simple rule and you can
write around this a little bit right but
as we know when we make requests like
these these rules can get infinitely
complicated right these rules can be a
the complexity of these can go far and
beyond just this one little example it's
hard to code for that so let's not let's
just make it very simple so let's create
something where we actually have
something that actually creates the
object for us so we create an employee
create request right so this is what
what we're doing here is we're breaking
things down into one request one request
class or definition one request
definition per per request that we're
making so we're going to end up making a
update request as well and you notice
that I'm just missing that property
straight up I'm not actually setting
that property at all it's not something
that a SP net becomes aware of even if
they post a birth number it doesn't
matter because it's because it's not
it's deserialize it's just an object
that c-sharp is aware of but birth
number gets thrown away right and then
we can do a delete request where we
simply just say hey we just want the ID
of the request and then something on the
other end can handle that okay so
another thing is is those required
attributes are little clunky to validate
especially if you're not using ASP net
right at some point you may end up using
something other than asp net and that
becomes very clunky to validate its this
is an example of the clunkiness right so
this is an example I pulled off a Stack
Overflow two links at the bottom of this
slide
somewhere and essentially they've just
done some attribute routing but they
needed some special behaviors right they
needed some special things that they
needed to do they needed additional
validation but you notice that well okay
first you got to do up a validation
result in you oh you implement this cool
I validate able object then that's a
that's an interface that defines a
validate method and you essentially
return them validation results and if
they're invalid and you know is it one
or more in validation result inside of
that set denotes an invalid object so
they try to validate that property and
you're like okay I'm going to validate
this property and then I'm going to new
up a validation context whatever that is
right I thought I was already getting
one but apparently I'm a new one up and
then I'm going to pass in null and
you're like I look at this and you're
like is that good is that bad like what
am i passing it maybe I maybe maybe it
needs that thing I'm supposed to avoid
no reference exception and you're
telling me I need to put null into this
it's very confusing the API is extremely
confusing and it's just not nice so
opinion here's the opinion warning I
have a library that I use called
fluent validation and fluid out
validation is game-changing well it's
life-changing it's maybe not as
life-changing it like having a kid but
it's certainly more life-changing than
this right it's more life-changing than
this this should just make you one that
to not be a developer so fluent
validations are really awesome library
and essentially what you do is you
define a single class so let's say let's
take our employee request first so we'll
just boil it down to just the first and
last name to keep it simple so what you
do is you just it's a separate class
becomes responsible for validating that
this class is valid so we want to have
isolate that validation functionality so
what we do is we create what's called an
abstract validator right or we've create
a class that's an employee create
validator and inherit from abstract
validator that's a class inside affluent
validation and then we give it the type
of the thing that we're validating so
that way we get strongly typed miss as
opposed to that new prop one stuff so I
don't even know right we don't have to
worry about all that because now we just
construct our object and then we say
here's a rule and here's the rule for
first name I don't want it to be empty
and
empty is great because the required
attributes are kind of kind of funny in
that you there's actually if you pass it
an empty string that's a vow that's
technically valid right unless you said
there's a required attribute as a
property set allow empty strings you can
set false and you can cover that but you
don't want to do that that's a lot of
typing right forget about it you want to
just say I want to make sure that this
thing is not empty and not empty means
not default value not know and in this
case not an empty string so it gives you
it it's better defined to the purpose
right you want a first or last name
attached to that employee it better
define to the purpose of that employee
because the first and last name should
never be empty strings either so that's
awesome
and they have a ton of methods that
allow you to build different validation
functionality you could say it has to be
equal to this you could say it has to be
a range of numbers right there's a lot
of stuff built in personally I
discovered it by simply gotten looking
at intellisense and seeing all the
different rules that are available and
you can do some pretty complex behaviors
right some pretty complex validation
it's better way better than that mess
that we saw so then you say I want to
say that first and last name were
required and I want to give a special
error message and this is a part where
resource strings really come in handy
because if you have to do English or
Norwegian because I'm in Norway right
you have to do English in Norwegian you
can use resource strings and you can
reuse those strings and it becomes very
nice cool so now we've separated our
validation behavior from our request our
request is no longer responsible for
also defining its own validation and for
a simple thing like first and last name
where you just need to say I just want
it required and I don't want empty
strings that's fine but validation
behavior can get pretty extensive right
all right we'll talk about that in a
second but first we've got to saut we
got to mention that testability right so
now we can test our validator separately
from our request right we don't have to
create a separate request new it up with
a bunch of stuff have create some
validation context where you're passing
in 40,000 nulls and you don't know what
that does that's good or bad you can
just say I'm going to do up the
validation request I'm going to validate
this object and then I'm going to make
sure that the validation error
that the validation errors have
something that has a first name and a
last name right and so that way when
Johnny junior developer or Jane junior
developer comes in and deletes that line
of code now you have a test to back that
up right because tests aren't really
written for just today to validate that
things work today there are also things
that work tomorrow for things that work
tomorrow right you want to guarantee
that behavior works tomorrow as well so
how so your validators can have some
complex behaviors you may need to talk
to a database to make sure that for your
delete request that something exists so
you may need to add that to your maiden
to add that to your constructor and then
you say I'm going to pass in an
application dbcontext and I just want to
make sure that it exists first and then
you get a cool API where you can kind of
write it in English or you know whatever
language you're writing it in right or
you could say like I'm going to define a
method called existing database and then
I call a method fluent validator has a
method called must must exist in
database it becomes very readable
becomes fluid it's a fluid API that's
kind of it's one of its design goals
we've separated our request model from
our entity and we've separated our
validation from our request model so
awesome we've created two totally
different things so we've done some good
work already
refactoring good the next let's get to
the meat of it right so we've done very
important steps but now we need to
extract those services and for this
thing we're going to talk about the post
request for this particular example
we're going to talk about the post
request right so it's creating it's
doing all this work is creating this
object and of course it's getting the
entity straight from the request which
is just crazy if you don't want that
right so now we're going to make it so
that we can do some we can save it to
the database but the controller doesn't
know how the controller doesn't really
care right so next opinion
ding-ding-ding the warning sign you know
something
it's like a big flashing red sign
opinion opinion alert right so I use a
library called mediator how many people
use auto member
lots of people use autumn after autumn a
purse auto magical okay
look it up if you haven't but autumn a
pers written by a guy named Jimmy Bogart
he's speaking at this conference and
Jimmy also wrote a library's
way lesser-known but in many ways just
as useful and for different things
though it's called mediator and it
essentially is kind of like a message
processing request inside of a process
right so mediator is really good at
separating requests from handlers
request handlers right so request comes
in the request handler handles it okay
and mediator is really good at that so
let's look with that let's take a look
at what that looks like
let's keep refactoring our application
so first things first we have our
employee create request just as we did
before with all the validations
separated out which is awesome that's
good we do our employee create request
and then you notice that this little
line right here we've changed it we've
added we've implemented an interface
called I request and I request as a
special interface it doesn't really do
anything it doesn't define behavior or
properties it's really a marker that's
what it is it says hey this object
represents a request I request as part
of the mediator library so this object
represents a request and then you give
it the return type when you create the
employee so one thing you need to know
probably that you might want to return
to the client the ID of the thing that
you've created right because it doesn't
get to choose its ID it's an auto
incrementing database so you just give
it the ID back so that's all we're
asking we're saying hey this request is
this is a request and it's going to
return an ID in the response right so
that's thing one we've changed our
request so now we've defined we're going
to do step two and we're going to
basically do the same thing that we did
pulling out the validation pulling out
the request but we're going to do it
with the service now we're going to
handle the post request we're going to
save that thing to the database we're
going to create that new thing and we're
going to add that to the service so
we're going to define a service with
that implements this I request handler
okay and you give it the request and
then they work the type of the request
and then the type of the response okay
what you're going to end up with is this
little method here called handle because
it actually does implement some behavior
and handle takes in the request and you
notice that it's return type is int just
like this right just like the thing that
we want to return we want to return the
ID of the object common question is well
what about async await there's
actually an eye a sink request an eye
space Inc request Handler and then
handle becomes the task event that what
it ends up returning okay so a sink away
totally totally available to mediator as
well so then we end up with our request
that creates our employee we set the
properties from that request and then we
save it to the date we add it to our
context if you're using entity framework
which we are and then we save it to the
database and then we return the new
employee ID and everybody's happy right
well I mean you happy if you're writing
plumbing code right nobody writes likes
to write properties like this objects as
we know can get huge I mean that's just
Lewis especially we're using legacy
applications we've got a god object and
it has 100 properties nobody wants to
type then you go to nimble text or some
kind of text editor that allows you to
like copy paste and just a mess right
and we don't have time for that there's
no time for that we don't have time for
that we don't want to write plumbing
code that's not where we're here for
we're here to sing so we're going to do
we're going to use Auto mapper right so
inside of the service we're going to
inject Auto mapper and Auto mappers a
way to map objects from one map objects
together so our employee create request
in this case can be mapped such that all
of its data can be transferred to a new
copy of an employee entity right we're
going to do this just to keep things
easy an auto map or does all the wiring
for you is the properties names are the
same then Auto mapper knows what to do
and it sets all those properties for you
and it's great so you inject in your
mapper you can add it as part of your as
in your services in your in your service
CS sorry your startup CS and add it in
there and add it as a service that's
available inside of your asp net
application right and then you can do
something like this which is a lot night
so you can create an employee then
you've just mapped it straight from that
right so save time so that way we're not
doing the whole property set thing which
you don't want to do and I don't want to
do it scaffold apparently scaffolding
didn't want to do either so that's
awesome so now we've ended up with a
service but where does it get validated
the service so I like to implement a
pattern where I create a common service
based class and I say
all of the requests all of the
validators that go in for this request
inject those straight in right if we
inject those straight into the
constructor and we say I'm going to go
ahead and validate all these I'm going
to run through each of those and I'm
going to check that of its valid and if
it's not I'm going to return some
validation results or throw about in
this kit usually I throw a validation
exception right I don't have the code
for this because it couldn't all fit on
the slide if you go to rest on eyes net
I link to a great Jimmy Bogart article
that shows you exactly how to do it
takes it step-by-step okay and we're
going to do all of our validation and
we're going to register those validation
in validators inside of start-up CS
right so it's going to be made available
to that service to use which is awesome
cool so now it's validating itself so I
create one base class that that
validates the request that I inherit
from that with all of my services right
and so I've created something that
reusable and repeatable in a very
lightweight way I just want to make sure
that my services are about my request
are validated and before you even
another common question that I get is
you know multiple validators why would
you just not have one you may have a
validator that's really good about
validating some very complex things
about your object that boiled down to
maybe touching one or two properties I
don't know I can't predict that you may
want to break up your validators is the
bottom line so you don't want to assume
that there's just one so we add
multiples because if you do assume
there's just one then a lot of
dependency injection libraries will just
return the first that it has and you may
not want that so we do multiples awesome
so it becomes independently testable so
now this service is really good at doing
its one thing so we're going to test an
assert that this be that this service is
really doing this really good one thing
and as of course it's reusable which we
described earlier we may want to use it
outside of an asp net core application
right we may want to do that we don't
know why but we may want to it's more
important that it be separate though
that's the most important takeaway so
let's put it all together
dependency injection handles
dependencies right so the thing that
where we configured all of our services
we added MVC to the pipeline we added
the application dbcontext
and now we've added in Auto mapper and a
bunch of other services and a bunch of
other validators to our pipeline right
we made those things all available
so that's what it does best it says this
thing is dependent on this thing so
we're going to create that thing with
all the things that it needs that like
enough things in that sentence
we're going to have mediator do the
request we're going to define requests
to mediator and then we're going to
define responses through mediator right
or in this case handlers the mediator is
doing that it's really good at defining
requests and handlers and then
controller will do what it does best
which is take an HTTP request do
something with it send it off to
somebody who knows what to do with it
and then return the data that's what the
controller's good at that's what the
controllers for it's like a traffic I
like to think of a controller as a
traffic cop
it just says okay you need to go here
you need to go here you need to go here
okay the bottom line is the next thing
is the that dependency injection was
never baked into asp net web api if
you're using web api looks like if
you're using web api you can add it in
of course you know you can add
dependency injection in very well but it
wasn't made a first-class citizen until
core so but i would recommend using a
better dependency injection container I
personally like Auto fact I see lots of
people use ninja
I see some use structure map it doesn't
really matter do something that just
makes your life easier in this way I
kind of use it like Auto mapper and I'll
show you how Auto mapper or Auto fact
will allow you will automatically scan
your assemblies you can say hey scan
this assembly for all of these
interfaces and just automatically add
them to the dependency injection
pipeline because you could depart the
you can define them one of the time say
I'm going to add this service than this
service but when you get to 100 services
in 100 validators that becomes pretty
heavy so you'd probably you may not want
to do that you may might be like me and
just want to get stuff done so what I
love to do with get stuff done so we're
going to do something like this we're
going to change our startup dot CS file
a little bit we're going to say hey I
want you to create this content to
create this container builder which is
an auto fact
thing that is built into Auto fact I'm
going to new that up and then I'm going
to say hey I want to scan every service
assembly because you may have your
services in a separate assembly you may
not depend on you but you want to do
right you may have you want to scan that
assembly and you just say I
want to register all the types as
implemented interfaces right and this
just goes through every single type and
every time it has an interface it says
okay this is an eye validator so when I
validator that validates employee create
request so when it's creating so when
it's something is asking for it gets
injected in right you can also filter
this down because you may not want that
behavior you may want to filter only the
things that implement I request or I
abstract abstract validator or or ice
async request handler or something like
that okay so do something save yourself
some time don't do them one at a time
use Auto fact use something use
something awesome right so then the
thing that you need to do is make sure
that mediator so you'll need to register
mediator as part of this part of this
whole process mediator is a thing that
is actually an object that is created it
actually handles that request we're
going to add it to that service pipeline
and then we're going to add it to the
controller so that the controller knows
who to ask for things right knows that
oh the mediator is the the god of all
requests and knows I don't know I just
present the request that the altar of
the mediator and then the mediator
blesses me with a response to that
request it takes that it takes that
create post request or create employee
request and routes it to wherever it
needs to go and out comes an ID and who
knows if it actually created something I
don't care because I'm the controller I
don't really want to know right so we
add that in of course we would add in
our application DB context here as well
still I just left it out for brevity and
then finally our controller we've
refactored so let's let's break this
down we refactored the request we've
taken the request separated it we've
taken the validator separated it we've
taken our service and separated it from
the controller so now the controller's
not left doing much which is great this
is the thing the controller should do
right so we say hey mediator handle this
request again I don't know what it's
doing I just know that you're going to
return an ID and that's awesome because
I'm going to assume that it went to a
database and happy flowers are growing
and everything is good everything is
good and great right I handle that
request and then we say hey creative
action right we want to return it can to
control
is good at saying hey httprequest here's
a response right here's how you get that
new employee that you just created right
and that's good and then if we have any
validation you can say hey I'm going to
throw an exception I'm going to catch
this validation exception and say if
there's any validation errors thrown I'm
going to go ahead and return bad
requests and then I'm going to give it
something with model state which this is
just an extension method that I define
myself if you want it you can ask me for
it I don't have a post anywhere I will
do that though in the next couple of
days on rest is net but essentially it
just creates a model state and just adds
all those error messages to that model
state okay
so let's wrap up with a few tips okay my
thing is creating repeatable patterns I
like to create repeatable patterns for
success so part of my job is I own a
consultancy and I have a junior
developer and giving her patterns to
repeat write something because she's
definitely into a development so I give
her patterns I say hey do this formula
and follow this through and this becomes
really powerful when you're training
junior developers because now you don't
have to say you know scaffold up 400
applicant 400 controllers for these
different objects right you can just say
hey I want you to do this methodically
and we want to build software right
especially if it's an API that somebody
else is consuming I've consumed tons of
bad api's which in my other talk you can
hear me tell all the horror stories but
imagine how powerful that becomes right
you say hey let's do this one step at a
time let's break this down we're going
to define our request what is our thing
going to do right what is it what is the
data that our things needs to do what
data does it need then I'm going to say
hey let's validate that request I'm
going to give you a list of business
rules and based on that ask fluent
validation to say hey ensure that this
string is empty ensure that this number
is between 0 and 100 right and
possibilities are endless there then you
say define a service and then you say
hey now we have our request we validated
it let's define let's inherit from this
base service that we've created that
automatically hooks all the validation
up and then you just implement the
handle interface and then save it to the
database delete it from the database you
know whatever right becomes very
powerful because you've broken it up
into finite steps and you're
testing all along the way to make sure
that your validator works properly that
your service is going to work properly
right because we all do unit testing
right right right they're better more
complete example Jimmy Bogaerts blog
right here on this link go ahead I'll
wait you click on it okay well we're
going to get this slide you can click on
that link and it's right there in the
links that I provide as well okay write
test for everything I can't emphasize
this enough now yeah and I have no
exceptions to that rule I just think you
should write test for everything and a
lot of people think that this slows them
down but it doesn't and there's plenty
of people who give good talks on why
testing is important so I'm not going to
beat it into your head I will just say
that it becomes the thing that is
powerful for testing for me is that it
becomes a spec it becomes the way your
software should behave it becomes and
not only does it become the spec it
guarantees that spec stays the same so
that when Jimmy jr. developer comes in
and deletes that line of code the whole
build comes crashing down because you
failed that one unit test and by the way
that functionality was really critical
and you have some consumers of your API
that really suck like me sitting under
not sending enough you know data to that
put request right
they didn't validate it I didn't send
enough data everybody screwed up so
avoid that I can tell you by the way
that the particular API that I used that
had this problem I talked to them it was
a SP net web api and no it wasn't backed
by a single unit test so they had a lot
of breaking changes between their
behavior I think that the my favorite
example of that was in my other talk day
I said they said oh yeah we changed some
stuff that happens under these couple of
endpoints nothing really changed from a
request standpoint you know just see let
us know if you have any problems we just
changed them underpinnings and we said
oh okay let's you know I want to run our
suite of unit integration tests to
guarantee that that stuff still works as
advertised and they said actually we're
deploying in one hour because we need it
right away and they're like well and
then you're stuck saying well I don't
know you we have about 500 customers
that depend on this API working properly
what are you going to tell do I want to
tell them why don't you have the
conversation with them in case your API
gets screwed up right and by the way
nothing broke that time but then other
times where things broke so right test
for everything I like to keep versions
separate this is another kind of
opinionated thing but if you're creating
a REST API you are probably going to
version it right and I talked about all
the strategies behind that and my other
talk but the bottom line is is that you
may have services that where the
employee only takes a certain number of
properties or maybe rename properties
from the next version of that where you
add in some behavior right so I like to
separate those into separate versions so
I have a separate assembly right where I
keep all those things I say here's my
separate version I'm going to say
version 1 version 1 services scan that
assembly put on all those services and
then the version 2 of my API has lots of
API 2 version you're doing a REST API or
any kind of API at some point you'll
probably version it as well and then you
can keep it in two separate assemblies
and then you can just add those to the
pipeline and that way everything's kept
nice and separate and then you have
another separate test project as well
right keeps everything nice and neatly
organized which is great so other bad
sides to this approach I think there are
right so it may be unnecessary
complexity if you're spinning up a
website they say actually we just want a
newsletter we just want to be able to
send a newsletter right and you're
trying to get something done quickly you
really just want you don't care about
that it's not business critical day to
say we just want a place where the text
box in a button right that may be
unnecessary to do something like this to
implement this huge amount of patterns
right I mean because the bottom line is
we don't want to spend a lot of time
doing that newsletter where there's two
controllers and all they're serving a
static static data except in this one
instance where it does a post request
and you're like I don't know I don't
care because like I mean you can do all
that stuff right apply all those
patterns but you may be just spinning
your wheels you may be doing something
that doesn't have a lot of value and
your boss probably will forget about it
next week anyways and then of course
there's a there's a bigger learning
curve and I'd say this with this one is
arguable arguable because there's kind
of a little bit of a learning curve in
breaking down how the controller handles
things at the surface it seems pretty
straightforward right it's talking to a
database it's you know deserializing a
request is routing that request and
saving it doing some stuff right so the
cognitive load
as your controllers get more complicated
the cognitive load can increase right so
this I mean you have to learn some more
libraries that's the bottom line you do
but once you get to that point things
become simpler your code becomes simpler
everything kind of simplifies because
well everything is doing the one thing
that it's really good at doing it's
really good at being a request it's
really good at being a validator right
that kind of stuff I find that this is
best for medium to large-sized
application so if you know your
application is going to grow you said
well the in the newsletter endpoint
isn't enough we need 14 more endpoints
to handle some very specific customer
behavior you may go back and say well I
may refactor or may apply this pattern
right because I want to I want to have
some strong guarantees about about this
is a customer facing thing or even some
internal facing thing that's business
critical and I want to have some strong
guarantees as it's going to function the
way that I've said it's going to
function so I'm going to go through and
apply this pattern and you'll and you'll
be rewarded for that right be rewarded
intrinsically because you'll know it
will work in the most part and then a
reliability right you don't have to
worry about controller being the single
source of failure now it's the course
entity framework are not talking to the
database maybe the database servers down
the true source of failure but it's kind
of masked right
because the controller is the one
responsible for knowing all that
information right you throw an exception
and then you have to go and say well it
threw an exception at employee
controller line 23 so then you dig into
the code maybe you're logging isn't good
you dig into the code you look at line
23 you're like oh that's the part words
save it to the database I should maybe
start there right whereas you might be
able to start a lot simple you're like
oh and and it failed at the validator
for XY and Z right makes things a little
less obscure and it makes your code
makes your code cleaner and that's a
good thing
this is really I don't have anything
else to say except all these resources
everything that I links to all this
stuff
resinize net take a picture look it up
later again I I answer questions all the
time about this kind of thing people
reach out to me all the time having to
give free advice so please reach out to
me on Twitter and usually I'm going to
I'm going to save questions at the end
in case anybody wants to go down and
join the awesome party that's about to
occur so
any questions you just come up to me on
the stage and I'll be happy to talk you
through your particular problem but the
bottom line is is thank you so much for
being here again please reach out to me
go to my website reach out to me again I
don't make any money on this no ads I
just want to help you if you have any
questions please feel free to reach out
I'm at schnide and Bach SAS at me comm
is my email address just go to my
website you find all that so thank you
so much again my name is Spencer strike
it's been a pleasure talking to you
thank you
[Applause]